[Music]
yeah we started my day little little
glimpse into the old PT routine nobody
nobody's curious about the old PT
routine I'll tell you what I do every
morning I drink a shot of wheatgrass
that's the right response one person
likes it that's the right ratio of
people to discuss I do I drink
wheatgrass it's not just for hippies and
pet psychics I don't know who drinks
wheatgrass
it's not just for them I drink it too
you ever drink wheatgrass its disgusting
but I drink it you know why it's good
for me but here's something I do every
night I drink whiskey that's right
whiskey you ever drink whiskey it's
disgusting but I do it cuz it's bad for
me that's what life is man yin yang baby
right dark go to the gym eat a cronut do
some yoga have some questionable sex
that's the bait using some of the same
poses mix it up balance I say wheatgrass
mornings and whiskey nights all the way
80% of my life is healthy it's dr. oz
approved 20% of my life
Ozzy Osbourne approved 80/20 your life's
gotta be 80/20 the 80% is what keeps you
alive long enough to enjoy the 20% that
gives you the stories that make your
life worth living that's what I'm saying
no one wants to hear your healthy
stories just like oh yeah the line the
line of juice it up the line of juices
ups real support them a woman's support
because they got organic sell celery I
call it self so so we got you're backing
away it's not a good short people don't
want a juice bar story people want to
dive bar story to spar stories have
words like ginger root and lemon cleanse
dive bar stories you have words like
whiskey ginger and go for yourself
that's a good story the 20% gives you
the interesting experiences you need
like with drinking drinking is an area
where you can bend your own rules even
if you're not a big drinker but if you
find yourself in Italy what are you
gonna do not drink of the wine in Italy
where they make of the one when in Rome
you're literally in Rome that's a time
for 80/20 have a glass of red I mean not
if you have a drinking problem it's ten
years clean but Holmes said it was okay
smash cut you're on top of the
restaurant like the Italian police are
like we got
smoking's another one smoking is
disgusting
I don't smoke it's one of the worst
things you can do but if I ever go to
Paris and I'm caught in some weird
sudden downpour you know Paris style I
duck into a quaint cafe and there's a
beautiful young woman who wraps me in a
blanket she probably made she gives me a
mug of wine kiss on the cheek haven't
even met her if twenty minutes into the
best conversation of my life with my
future French soul mate she hands me a
single hand rolled filterless French
cigarette that she did this with
[Applause]
you damn right I'm going to flavor
country in the morning I'll go for a jog
but now drunk wet French Pete I'm gonna
inhale some carcinogens that have a
certain genetic wow look to be honest a
lot of 80/20 for me is to impress a girl
that's true if you offer me a piece of
cheesecake a clove cigarette and a 2:00
p.m. cosmopolitan and I say yes I'm
trying to have sex with you and that's
okay because that's an experience so
will the sex be never deprive yourself
of a genuine experience or the sex like
ice cream I don't need ice cream I know
it's a disappointment I got one of those
I love ice cream faces but I don't
really put dairy but if after our
cigarette the French girl wants to
spoon-feed me a tiny french spoonful of
her french vanilla from that impossibly
cold steel dish that she's just like I'm
not gonna turn my mouth away like a
finicky toddler just like 80/20 eat an
ice cream your life is falling away eat
it
enjoy it I'm sure as hell not just gonna
sit there and watch her eat ice cream
alone like some creepy perv with a weird
fetish yeah this is rocking my road
this is cream in my cookies
this is jumping my hubby
none of them eat the ice cream 8020
drugs - that's right
Pro drugs if you're backpacking through
Europe and you wind up in Amsterdam like
so many people just wind up in Amsterdam
eat the pot brownie I don't care if you
don't do drugs or if you've never done
pot before eat it I don't care just on
your Mormon mission just like Holmes
said it's okay it's not gonna kill you
you may think it'll kill you do I have
to tell my lungs to breathe Jim I think
I have to tell my lungs to breathe well
you're not gonna die don't worry the
Dutch will understand that's what they
do you're over there drooling in the
corner I'll just leer a little bit just
be like stupid American how do you do a
stupid him can anyone here do a Dutch
accent
what about I'll settle for German we got
stupid American stupid America
[Applause]
what is this audience we got yeah
helpful hecklers you're doing a great
job
[Applause]
[Music]